are critics saying yes or no to nope it
might just be a little bit of both and
we've got the review roundup right here
i ain't never seen yeah nothing like
this
no
in 2017 jordan peele wrote produced and
directed get out which was met with
great acclaim and earned peel and oscar
for best original screenplay he followed
that up with 2019's us which received
glowing responses from critics like
richard brody of the new yorker who
wrote it captures the transformative
radical power of a political conscience
of an idea long held in secret as it
ripens and develops over decades worth
of time us is nothing short of a
colossal achievement needless to say
anticipation for his next movie has been
sky high on july 22nd peele will release
his third feature film titled nope
starring kiki palmer daniel kaluya and
steven yoon the trailer teases viewers
with a mysterious story set in a desert
community experiencing what looks to be
visitations from extraterrestrial beings
but in classic peel fashion there
appears to be far more going on than a
simple synopsis could reveal although
proper reviews for the movie have yet to
be released critics have been giving
their first reactions to the film on
social media and we now know a bit more
about what nope has in store and how it
stacks up compared to peel's previous
efforts based on the first batch of
reactions to nope it looks as though
jordan peele has another success on his
hands on twitter shannon mcgrew of
nightmarish conjuring said of the film
nope is otherworldly yet indescribable
from instances of sheer terror to
heartfelt moments between the characters
nope is an experience that won't be easy
to shake off as you find yourself
picking your jaw up from the floor
jordan peele has done it again others
also heaped praise on peel's latest
venture with collider steven weintraub
tweeting that he doesn't want to give
anything about the movie away other than
that it gets his stamp of approval
fandango and rotten tomatoes writer eric
davis said that nope is one of his
cinematic highlights of the year and
added what i love most about nope is the
storytelling it's peel's biggest film
yet the sound is incredible but the
story is clever and always evolving the
characters are so well written you're
invested from the moment it starts and
you'll want to talk about it long after
it's over eric eisenberg of cinema blend
tweeted that nope continues in the
successful footsteps of peel's previous
films writing it's a summer spectacle
about spectacle and while there are many
flavors mixed in it's particularly an
excellent tribute to jaws peel is three
for three several other critics weighing
in also compared the film to steven
spielberg classics including freelance
writer brandon norwood who tweeted
really liked nope like a cross between
jaws and close encounters jordan has
created a very unique sci-fi horror epic
on the other hand cnn's frank pallada
had a few different points of reference
he said the movie felt inspired by 1950s
genre cinema and added jordan peele has
been compared to hitchcock but nope
shows he's a next-gen carpenter enjoy
the show and don't look up while the
general consensus of these early
reactions to nope has been mostly
positive some did offer more nuanced
criticisms of the film critic simon
thompson even wrote jordan peele's nope
is his most confident unfettered and
potentially most divisive vision yet
writer shay wiley offered a positive
reaction to the movie but cautioned
readers to not expect another us she
summed up her thoughts with is it
intriguing absolutely is it frustrating
just a little is it scary nope you can
watch this i promise i told y'all the
trailer wasn't gonna be what we thought
it was gonna be some were outright
critical of the film journalist nestor
benticore aka nestor cine tweeted
peelcraft's a series of immersive scenes
and the talented cast gives a hundred
percent but the contrived and
confounding script sinks a promising
original film with shades of jaws and
signs my biggest question among many
will the audience feel challenged or
trolled meanwhile critic sharonda
williams called nope the weakest of
jordan peel's films and specifically
criticized the execution of the story
despite these detractors most of those
weighing in on social media thus far
appear to think that nope is another
peel masterpiece as youtuber straw hat
movies wrote nope is making a strong
case for my favorite movie of the year
it's what jordan said it was a spectacle
you can see the spectacle for yourself
when nope hits theaters on july 22nd
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you